hallo mein name ist so herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge will yoopress
debatten dot com
ich habe das bei justin gesehen bei
apple bei vielen menschen die das
schokoladen haben bei diesem spiel geht
es darum dass wir in der mitte diesen
knopf hier haben wo diese dass das ganze
spiel besteht versetzt diese animation
also alles andere sind nur komische
website die sonst nur laden als erwartet
nichts großartiges wir haben hier unten
zwei auswahlmöglichkeiten und zwar
einmal you can get into die beste page
die programme the world but you feel
like every day also wir haben jetzt
quasi aus weil es mit etwas gutem auf
dieser seite und etwas schlechten auf
dieser seite und jetzt müssen uns
entscheidungen machen wir das oder
machen wir das ganze nicht da ich mich
nicht wie ein kompletter vollidiot
fühlen will weil ich weiß wie das ist
wirklich einfach auf wohnort und ich bin
in der minderzahl mindert das mindert
dann steht ihr noch ray disc dilemma 37
ex honda sondern sagen ob das gut ist
oder schlecht ich sagen das habe ich
noch gar nicht nicht verstanden ich höre
ich sage einfach mal das ist schlecht
keine ahnung als nächstes haben wir die
auswahlmöglichkeit zwischen einerseits
ich kann immer wenn ich will mich in ein
tier verwandeln und wieder zurück zu
einem menschen und immer wann ich will
es gibt keine limits also auch wenn ich
irgendwie total schlimm situation gerade
als tier wird und kurz vorm sterben kann
ich sagen okay ich bin jetzt ein anderes
tier und bin halt nicht mehr am sterben
quasi human values das gegenteilige
hiervon es allerdings dass ich wenn ich
ein mensch bin einfach kein
geschlechtsverkehr haben kann deswegen
würde ich auch sagen abbott und ich bin
in der mehrheit die nächste sache ist
dass alle leute die ich liebe glücklich
für den rest des lebens sind allerdings
werde ich von jedem nahezu gehasst ich
das ist
total schwer auf der einen seite ist es
halt so dass man will dass jeder
irgendwie möglich ist den man gern hat
aber auf der anderen seite will man
natürlich selbst auch nicht gehasst
werden deswegen ist das für mich
ich sage einfach mal schauen vielleicht
freunde die nächste sache ist übel krank
you have my hometown transformed into
place yourself also meine heimatstadt
oder die stadt wo ihr halt wohnt wird
quasi virtualisiert als gta
computerspiel strahler dings ist es so
dass jede person die ich in dem spiel
töte das heißt ihr spiel der spiele der
eigenen stadt als ihr selbst wenn wir
ihnen treu und siehst du tötest ihnen
die pflicht und in einer mission am ende
muss man jemanden töten der einem nahe
steht also irgendwie ein
familienmitglied oder eine freundin oder
keine ahnung was ich sage so schön diese
vorstellung auf ist nicht jeder hat sich
schon mal gewünscht ist die kleine stadt
in der man aufgewachsen ist in dem
computerspiel drin dass man alles mich
kaputt machen ganz sage ich trotzdem
augen nord und 71 welche kranken 29
prozent sagen ja was ist los mit euch
alter ich wollte gerade wirklich diese
seite neu laden aber dann habe ich
entdeckt das untendrunter immer so ein
paar kommentare stehen und da steht
jetzt und der kommentar wurde vor 46
jahren geschrieben
das war 1970 da gab es nicht mal essen
die nächste single stars auf der einen
seite kennen wir alle geheimnisse des
universums
aber die sind einfach behindert
also keiner wird mir glauben ich würde
es trotzdem machen als es ist mir
scheißegal ob die mir glauben oder nicht
solange ich es weiß und ich weiß dass es
die wahrheit ist 62 haben auf jahr
gedrückt da bin ich auf jeden fall schon
mal eine mehrheit ich sag mal die sache
war gut und wir schauen jetzt mal als
nächstes you can eat and celebrity get
your life but the world as if you are
not der ja auf jeden fall wenn ich die
möglichkeit doch hab die zu treffen ist
mir scheißegal ob die wissen ob ich da
bin oder nicht natürlich meisters
wolfsegg in slate 46 machen das nur das
hat man denn dadurch für nachteil denn
überhaupt mal nach bevor du etwas
drücken you can understand every
language that nobody can understand unit
in englisch alter das ist krank das
heißt quasi dass ich jeden menschen
weltweit egal in welchem land ich würde
verstehen was sie sagen allerdings wenn
ich dann antworten möchte denken die
sich nur suchen was will davon mirka 370
prozent sagen dass gleich ein nobody
listen to me anyway
ich verstehe gar nicht wie kann man mit
dieser website auswählen dass man vor 46
jahren einen kommentar geschrieben hat
das ist doch echt das ist da kann nicht
sein hier diese sache hier ist ultra
krank und zwar hat man das beste haus
auf der kompletten welt allerdings jeden
tag um 3 uhr mittags kommt eine riesige
welle an spinnen durch das haus niemals
alter
die nächste sache ist krass und zwar man
kann die zeit für zehn sekunden anhalten
aber in dieser zeit verschwinden die
karotten
ich würde definitiv machen 51 prozent
sind auch mal hätte auf der einen seite
kann ich acht sprachen sprechen die ich
mir selber aussuchen kann allerdings auf
der anderen seite bin ich dabei komplett
am stottern ich würde aber trotzdem
machen also ist es ja besser so derzeit
spreche ich irgendwie deutsch englisch
bisschen spanisch und latein wenn man
das als sprache nennen kann aber wenn
ich mir jetzt noch acht andere sprachen
aussuchen könnt wie beispielsweise
japanisch chinesisch weil sie nicht noch
sechs andere sprachen natürlich das tape
machen auch wenn ich dann schon dann
wird es dann besser als wenn ich nicht
könnte also ich drücke drauf und einmal
denken die nicht nach wie sie mal das
ist doch mal gar keinen sinn aber an
dieser stelle sage ich tschüss meine
lieben freunde des videos verweist tut
mir leid falls ein wenig komisch war ja
ich weiß ich bin total müde irgendwie
wenn euch das video allerdings gefallen
hat und ihr euch eventuell denkt ja das
ist sehr schön gewesen dann zeigt es mit
einer bewertung gibt einen daumen hoch
und wenn wir 100 tausend daumen hoch
knacken sollten dann mach ich mal ein
video wo ich ein